and now please give a big hand to
ba yeah uh welcome to my lightning talk
polary syntactic sugar for your
conditional pox Expressions first off
who has actually heard about uh
polers okay quite some few uh so
consider this this punas example on the
left here which is just some standard P
code where we want to find our top
paying customers so uh top paying
customers being C customers who paid
more than 500 in total over their whole
contract duration and we do so by first
figuring out like the daily rate they
paid then how long they actually uh were
our customers so we figure out the
number of days their contract run and
then just filter it the equivalent polar
code would look something like this with
the main difference being that instead
of uh how pandas computes this uh like
uh doing the computation step by step
and uh Computing all the intermediate
results so the number of days you
customer and the total price and then
only filtering we first build up a
symbolic expression which can then be
evaluated upon your data frame so here
we we craft up this expression which is
not actually directly Computing anything
and then we can call this filter
function on the data frame and filter
out all rows where this is being larger
than 500 um so this was great we can
also do um this this saves a lot of um
uh intermediate storing of intermediate
results so this results in a great speed
up and we can also do conditional
Expressions so consider we have some
column X which is just a number and we
want to find the Signum function of of
this number so um the equivalent Pol
code was would look something like this
where we would use this polers when then
otherwise chain and as you can see the
condition goes in here and if this is
true it should return one and if it's
not the case it will do a nested
statement like this but you can also
kind of see the problem here where it
becomes quite a a bit hard to read and
write especially if nesting comes into
uh play and this is where polary comes
into the picture instead of having to uh
write this function on left manually you
can just add a function decorator to
your Signum function on polary will then
convert the uh a of your function into a
polar expression so consider we have
some some expression to get our number
X here you can just pass it into the
Signum function and get out a new
expression which will be the Signum
function value of your of your of your
uh expression essentially so let's take
a quick look at how polary dust this um
polary um goes through your function
body uh statement by statement and keeps
track of all the assignments you have
made along the way and what conditions
uh it has encountered so we start off
with this first statement with s being
just assigned zero and then we go on to
the first uh condition statement so um
we we note down that if x has been
larger than zero s will be assigned to
one and if it's not the case um s will
still remain at zero we then reach this
second conditional block Alf remember El
if is just syntactic sugar for a if
block inside the else Clause so we
replace this uh uh s being equal to zero
statement down here with another
conditional block um and now the
condition is if x is being smaller than
zero s will be assigned to minus one and
if not s will still remain at zero we
then Reach This return statement and uh
now we need to figure out what s final
value will be in each branch so we
basically just inline s with the final
value we can look it up in the
assignment uh we have kept uh have been
keeping track of and uh then have buil
up this this graph which uh notes down
what each one should return now polary
only needs to translate this into a
final polus expression um so this is
pretty straightforward we uh we copy
this this condition here inside uh as
the argument for this when function call
the left side goes in the as the
argument for the St function call and
the right side will be the otherwise
call we do this recursively and get out
the final expression and then polary
will just replace the function body with
the polar expression so you can use it
throughout your code base um so this was
a super quick look at how polary works
if you want to check it out in detail uh
feel please feel free to do so at uh our
guub repository uh you can find polary
on pipie and Conor Forge and thanks for
your
attentions